bonsoir Monsieur roi je vais commencer
par Montréal une partie parce qu'on en a
parlé en début d'émission beaucoup de ce
casse-tête avec Louis paulite Lafontaine
des problèmes de circulation des
gens disaient après des gens préoccupés
du centre-ville il faut qu'on coordonne
encore mieux que ce n'est le cas
actuellement les différents chantiers
parce que les gens vont devenir fou
c'est le poumon économique de mon du
Québec Montréal est-ce que ça vous
inquiète puis est-ce qu'on peut faire
mieux
se coordonner par exemple moi je veux
voir le revitaliser le centre ville de
Montréal les gens reviennent travailler
d'autre part des problèmes de congestion
On a Froid travailler sur des mesures
d'atténuation il est clair que la
Réunion centre-ville est importante
c'est clair que Montréal c'est un centre
important pour la contribution au Québec
à la fois travailler avec le transport
l'habitation aussi c'est classe
parce que ça je sais pas si vous avez vu
en fin de semaine dans les nouvelles le
temps que ça prenait à Yves Montréal il
y a quelque chose des parents là dedans
là on veut pas paralyser la région de
Montréal effectivement
c'est clair qu'au niveau du transport ça
prend des mesures de dénation puis il
faut falloir aussi travailler avec ils
ont un travail peut-être flexible le
transport routier évidemment qui est
important le transport des camions par
exemple important aussi est-ce que vous
pourriez arriver avec des annonces genre
tous nos employés de la région de
Montréal restaient à la maison tel jour
et camionnage nouvelle réglementation
est-ce que vous planchez sur des choses
concrètes madame Guilbaud est
présentement là-dedans puis on s'est
parlé encore aujourd'hui de communiquer
il faut faire aimer comme il faut parce
que d'une part moi j'aurai plus de monde
à Montréal d'autre part s'il peut pas
rentrer on voit des problèmes donc faut
travailler que les entreprises je pense
qu'il faut trouver une façon on a pour
deux ans deux ans et demi donc c'est
clair on va voir faire des ajustements
et avoir des mesures proactives bon vous
êtes ministre responsable d'Hydro-Québec
on l'a beaucoup souligné depuis jeudi
vous avez vu cette caricature que je
vous montre de chapeaux dans la presse
où on voit
découvrir on la voit on la voit plein
écran ne t'inquiète pas fit c'est moi
l'arbitre donc monsieur Lego entre vous
deux il y a vous c'est le super héros là
de la claque et Madame Brochu c'est une
caricature mais il y a c'est intéressant
parce que Monsieur LEGO a créé un comité
chose extrêmement rare pour gérer les
visions différentes d'Hydro-Québec et
et de votre vision à vous je pense que
je corriger un peu ça parce que
premièrement le comité en question qui
était ma recommandations en passant on a
déjà eu avant ça fait déjà un an qu'on
travaille il y avait monsieur Julien il
y avait monsieur Legault et moi pour
regarder l'enjeu numéro 1 c'est qu'on a
des projets qui sont souhaitables pour
le Québec et souhaitable pour des fins
environnementales
souhaitable pour la création de richesse
la filière batterie par exemple les deux
doivent être à conciliation on peut
mettre en porte-à-faux ou en opposition
l'économie l'environnement existe déjà
alors
pour travailler ensemble pour décider
comment on va allouer nos capacités
hydroélectriques ou éoliennes dans les
projets portables Québec vous dites
c'est pas pour faire l'arbitrage genre
parfois de l'arbitrage nécessaire il y a
des conceptions qui se posent même si
ils sont pas à chaque jour opposé par
exemple on va écouter madame Brochu
c'est très court restez là sur le le
vent de l'électricité à bas prix pour
attirer des entreprises on l'écoute
l'image que j'ai que je donne c'est
qu'on veut pas être le magasin dollar de
l'électricité renouvelable dans le monde
on veut que les gens reconnaissent la
valeur de motricité on va New York les
New Yorkais le reconnaissent alors
pourquoi au Québec on serait pas capable
de demander ça en s'assurant qu'on soit
concurrentiel dans le monde mais pas pas
dans le bonbon à celle
on veut pas devenir dit Madame Brochu et
Monsieur faitgaben ça s'adressait un peu
à vous dans une certaine mesure en
disant il veut des jobs c'est normal il
veut de l'emploi il va attirer des
entreprises partout sa planète en disant
venez au Québec l'électricité pas cher à
l'instant on va pas construire des
barrages pour attirer des entreprises
qui vont entre guillemets gaspiller
l'électricité il y en a deux visions qui
s'affrontent
périmètre comptable des profits le
gouvernement il y a un autre périmètre
comptable monsieur Gérard aussi fait des
revenus avec les entreprises alors le
point ici c'est que on peut pas regarder
uniquement la profitabilité du Québec
dans l'embauché d'accord avec ça on
parle de l'aluminium par exemple les
retombées économiques de l'aluminium sur
le Saguenay par exemple peut-être sont
beaucoup supérieurs
la profitabilité qu'on a chez au Québec
alors le point de du comité de
transition énergétique c'est pas faire
la littérale c'est de permettre à
edo-québec de comprendre l'ensemble de
l'oeuvre vous voulez la convaincre
si on décide de vendre l'électricité à
une compagnie a qui va payer un peu
moins cher que ce que les New-York et
paient mais conséquemment on crée des
emplois on crée la fiscalité accrue pour
Monsieur Girard ça va être bénéficiaire
un des problèmes du Québec moi je vais
adresser c'est qu'on doit garder nos
ressources et les transférer créé de la
valeur jusqu'au produit final alors une
anecdote j'ai arrêté le chancelier
moi on peut tout savoir de l'hydrogène
vert j'ai répondu à plaisantant jamais
vous avez des véhicules verts on va
faire vos Mercedes au Québec
plaisanterie que j'ai fait attention il
faut regarder l'ensemble de la
conception elle son emploi c'est de
regarder Hydro-Québec et que vous votre
vue est plus large que la sienne c'est
pour ça vous avez pas nécessairement le
même avis à tous les jours et conséquent
pour pallier à ça madame Bochu va
pouvoir comprendre qu'une plus grande
transparence qui va être réciproque
quels sont les retombées économiques au
Québec en sud de ce qui devrait peut
faire alors je pense ça va être une
communauté qui va être très
performante mais vous dites elle va
comprendre monsieur faitgaben c'est très
clair que dans votre esprit c'est elle
qui doit comprendre et pour vous qui
doit comprendre ce qu'elle dit le mot
comprendre que trop fort mais elle avait
pas toutes l'information l'information
pour déterminer quelle est la
contribution d'un projet d'une
entreprise dépasse les bornes des au
Québec alors ce que je dis c'est qu'il
faut que les fesses soient bien
communiquer à tous les pas excluants la
population en passant parce que si on
parle d'autant d'Hydro-Québec c'est
qu'il y a des décisions qui vont toucher
tout le monde en jeu les nouveaux
barrages par exemple on peut se poser la
question c'est pas tellement les
nouveaux barrages oui mais pourquoi
faire est-ce que c'est pour vendre à
très bas prix au Québec ou est-ce que
c'est pour exporter est-ce que pourquoi
on veut faire des nouveaux barrages
c'est l'un des bol vraiment les
résultats c'est pas une stratégie la
première chose qu'on doit faire si on
regarde la demande
[Musique]
entrepreneur peu importe d'où il vient
sur la planète vous dit moi je vais vous
créer 2000 emplois ou 1000 emplois mais
j'ai besoin d'électricité à très bas
coût votre côté homme d'affaires vous
dites oui on va accepter et de l'autre
côté elle a dit c'est pas nécessairement
le bon affaire c'est ça le débat mais je
pense de deux extrêmes par exemple déjà
il y a des clients qui vont payer le
tarif vidéo électrique qui est en
corrélation avec le proftabilité ou le
prix des produits qui vont le vendre
pourquoi ne parlez plus loin là-dedans
moi je pense il faut faire attention de
dire tout simplement qu'on donne
l'électricité il profite du Québec ces
profits importants
la question c'est l'arbitrage
l'arbitrage d'un orbitrage de
différentes personnes et moi je pense
que comprendre je me suis exprimé il
faut que au Québec
est toute l'information d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui
j'ai pas toutes les formations dans la
décision là ça va être plus compliqué
parce que il va avoir pas cela un manque
de projet alors ce sont des nécessaires
c'est d'inclus des inclus madame Brochu
dans le processus décisionnel vous dites
puis dernière question là-dessus
pierrefitbull on a décidé de l'inclure
si vous ne l'aviez pas fait à se réparti
je sais pas vous le savez non pas
vraiment
elle dit qu'elle veut rester parce
qu'elle est si rare qu'on annonce quand
même ces comité-là la journée d'un
nouveau gouvernement on sent que ça a du
brasser en coulisses un peu là
je sais pas mais je peux vous dire que
c'est rencontre là c'est pas une
première j'ai rajouté madame Brochu et
Monsieur Julien reprises dans l'autre
mandat non c'est pas c'est pas une
nouvelle création formelle tout le monde
vous reconnaît monsieur faitgiben le
grand talent de vouloir amener des
projets qui vont créer de l'emploi qui
vont créer de la richesse je devrais
dire soit toujours de l'emploi mais qui
vont créer de la richesse au Québec
est-ce que
ayant ça en tête des fois vous perdez de
vue des histoires le Journal de Montréal
encore ce matin qui disait vous avez
votre ministère a signé un chèque de 24
millions un entreprises qui dont des
actionnaires des administrateurs vous
avez travaillé avec eux vous étiez
proche de pourquoi vous mettez pas sur
place un processus que vous allez vous
retirer de toute discussion si vous
cédez à vous vraiment
je pourquoi il y a une rigueur au
gouvernement c'est un projet qui était
piloté par Investissement Québec les
gens duomis qu'installer chez nous là
aux entreprises alors je pense qu'avant
de porter des jugements sur une
situation vaut mieux comprendre la
situation
autorisé 24 millions de dollars pour
cette entreprise-là
2017 s'il fallait que tous les projets
comme ça je me retire jamais
vous avez été administrateur un collègue
à vous et toujours là est-ce que dans ce
cas-là vous devriez dire très bien que
mon souligner soit d'autres prennent la
responsabilité de signer l'autorisation
pour envoyer un chèque on dit pas que le
chèque aurait pas dû être envoyé on dit
d'être prudent je suis prudent de par la
nature du processus d'autorisation des
investissements
il n'est pas de confié intérêt alors je
comprends l'enjeu je comprends qu'il
faut être sensible à ça il faut être
prudent les mesures sont déjà en place
donc il y a aucun cas vous voulez vous
retirer si vous avez déjà travaillé de
près avec certaines personnes on dit pas
connaître vous connaissez tout le monde
parce que je suis en train de dire mais
déjà avec qui vous avez travaillé vous
devriez pas avoir la prudence de vous
retirer du processus décisionnel j'étais
membre du conseil d'administration la
caisse de 8 j'étais exécutif à la Banque
Nationale si on voit ça se théorie là je
suis allé au ministère
de conflit d'intérêt pendant 4 ans oui
parce que à l'intérieur je suis
totalement à l'aise il n'y aurait jamais
de confié intérêt il n'aurait jamais
alors faut vivre avec le croire que le
système rigoureux je pense qu'il
Investissement Québec et vous allez
économie et le gouvernement il y a des
procédures en place pour empêcher de
conflit intérêts
vous avez l'appui complet de votre
patron le Premier ministre là-dessus et
vous dire t'en fais pas
lui il dit
et je ne suis pas en confiée et on peut
dire tout ce qu'on veut des journaux là
faut faire attention je ne suis pas
propriétaire alors je pense que c'est ça
est-ce que vous êtes bien fait de Gabin
inquiète des prochains mois que
Desjardins aujourd'hui dit au Québec on
va y aller en récession d'abord elle
vous convaincu de ça 1 et 2 quel est
votre stratégie qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire comment on peut se mettre à l'abri
je pense que récession ou non il y a
relativement économique on a pour 12 à
18 mois 2023 était difficile il y a
l'enjeu des individus là je pense qu'on
est un programme pour le bouclier
fiscal Monsieur Girard mettre en place
il faut aider l'inflation de ce réseau
pro à court terme conséquent des
individus on est incroyable très classe
sur ça les entreprises ou je suis
responsable ce qu'on voit c'est les
chaînes d'approvisionnement sont brisés
conséquemment on va boire encore par une
coupe d’année
je pense que oui
québécoises alors les entreprises ont
besoin de liquidité pour avoir un
inventaire des produits pour souffrir à
la demande le 18 un petit peu mais il y
a quand même il y a quand même des
problèmes alors nous faut pallier à ça
il va avoir des programmes on va mettre
en place pour ceux qui ont besoin de
liquidité pour avoir les inventaires
pour pouvoir livrer les produits
heureusement à cause du plein emploi les
entreprises sont pas en mauvaise
conditions financière afin de faire des
crédits des grosses pertes plus une
question de liquidité alors je pense que
faut être très attentif je pense qu'on a
pour deux ans comme ça deux gens et donc
chiens d'approvisionnement briser ça
implique inflation à automatiquement
taux d'intérêt qui vont continuer à
augmenter
bon pour les entreprises une chose pour
les Québécois qui ça n'existent c'est
une autre chose aussi il va vanter fort
pour
24 mois vous êtes on pense si la fin
2023 je pense que effectivement les taux
d'intérêt qui augmentent c'est pour
adresser l'inflation je pense qu'on va
voir une réduction de l'inflation ça pas
du jour au lendemain une bonne tendance
mais on a pour les individus ça va être
complexe pendant encore plusieurs mois
on va régler ça avec les mesures
fiscales pour les entreprises c'est pour
avoir de liquidité comme on a fait
durant la pandémie avec des programmes
qu'on avait mis en place
vous êtes étourdi des fois parce que là
vous en avez encore plus là que je le
disais au Québec Montréal Montréal il y
a des ponts à rebâtir aussi vous êtes
conscient de ça
je suis content d'avoir Montréal parce
qu'il faut arrêter de parler de Montréal
et du québecueil
je pense ça va être important moi je
vais être le ministre de tous les
montréalers on était on est d'une équipe
qui veut gagner pour gagner tout le
monde tout sur le même patinoire moi je
suis très enthousiaste je suis très
commis engagé et Madame plante et moi
avons un très bon rapport je suis très
heureux pour être avec elle on va se
reparler à plusieurs reprises monsieur
Facebook merci de nous le voir merci au
revoir